my own cat Orville got killed by a car I
decided to turn it into a drone
as a tribute to his untimely death
I had no idea about remote-control
helicopters anything my initial thought
was it's kind of crazy but my second
thought was let's do it
ostriches can't fly so we make them
fight
[Music]
everything is better when it flies
the trays of salmon salad are better
when they're flying
[Music]
will excrete a tough jet before - out of
his backside
it's actually human interference that
makes me get the animals we only use
roadkill and they're already dead it's
just a result of us being here on this
planet and doing what we do and I
collect the leftovers that's what I do
in principle anyone who has a dead
animal can come to us and we make him an
offer to make him fly
[Music]